[Musique]
bonjour ber président du mfine bienvenu
ici au bistro du théâtre je vous en prie
merci le bistre du théâtre à Montini qui
a l'abitude de nous recevoir pour ce
café politique aujourd'hui c'est un peu
particulier on a plutôt l'habitude
d'accueillir des hommes des députés des
maires des conseillers régionaux cette
fois-ci on fait une petite exception une
petite entorse à cette règle déjà parce
que l'actualité l'impose on prendra le
temps de parler avec vous de cette loi
travail de cette réforme le 9 mars il y
a une forte mobilisation dans dans les
rues parisiennes et pas uniquement
d'ailleurs et puis aussi parce que ce
sera l'occasion de mieux comprendre
comment fonctionne l'organisation votre
organisation le medf et qui sont ceux
qui la dirigent d'ailleurs pour situer
un petit peu tout de suite les les
choses faut-il être de droite pour être
au
MDF je ne crois pas qu'il faille aide ni
de droite ni de gauche c'est pas une
organisation politique parce que souvent
l'image du meddef est associée à celle
de la droite plutôt c'est un cvage un
vieux cliché on fait un amalgame patron
riche patron de droite c'est faux le
MDEF c'est une organisation qui défend
l'entreprise donc l'entreprise et et
d'ailleurs c'est ça que j'étais hier
avec je des yeux et mon administration
du MDEF Yveline et un de mes adhérents
c'est prent à Jof bieux qui venait nous
rencontrer moi je suis un patron de
gauche et il est dit je suis un patron
de gauche et quand de m'a recruté je
luii dit écoute je suis socialiste et de
gauche les patrons ils ont
diversesilités ça les regarde par que ça
les regarde est-ce que vous vous
l'affichez votre sensibilité est-ce que
vous vendiquez être un patron de gauche
ou un patron de droitite alors à titre
personnel je ne réponds que pour moi là
je suis ni de droite ni de gauche je
suis un homme d'entreprise B mais
maintenant j'ai dans mon mouvement des
hommes qui ont affiche et c'est leur
droit des sensibilités bien précises qui
sont de droite ou de gauche mais ce
n'est pas le le débat au MEF le premier
président auef lors de sa création
c'était Erneste Antoine séier c'était en
2002 qu'il déclarait que le Medef était
justement non partisan il ne porte aucun
jugement aucune opinion sur les
candidats il ne donne aucune consigne de
vote pourtant le MDF en 2007 était
plutôt opposé à Segolen royale notamment
en raison des des 35 he et puis en 2012
le meddef s'est aussi prononcé contre le
programme économique du Front national
c'est aussi le le rôle du meddeef alors
je pense que voyez c'est une évolution
et
Cère a fixé les bases d'un mouvement
mais il s'est passé un peu de temps
depuis lui il y a eu Pariso il y a eu
pierre
gataz et alors ça c'est encore une fois
ma conviction mais vous savez le MF
c'est un mouvement qui rison beaucoup
d'entreprises des grandes des petites
des toutes petites des très grosses et
des patrons très divers donc à titre
personnel et je n'exprime que pour moi
Mo je pense que nous devons nous avons
un devoir de parole un devoir de parole
et lorsqu'un candidat c'est pas que nous
soyons nous opposons systématiquement
droite ou gauche mais quand un homme
politique prend une parole défin
économique nous avons mon mon avis le
devoir de donner notre avis bien ou mal
que pensons-nous de ce programme pour
les entreprises vous avez cité justement
pierre gataz le président actuel du MEF
dès son arrivée il a dit souhaitit
durcir les positions du meddef baisser
les pensions de retraite sur la hausse
de la durée des cotisations le report de
l'âge légal aussi vous en pensez quoi de
de ces propositions et puis quel regard
vous avez aussi sur sur l'homme sur
pierre gataz qui a un style un petit peu
différent de de ce a précédé tout à fa
tout à fait euh pierre Gatas est un chef
d'entreprise un vrai un vrai euh si on
reprend son parcours il a il a
effectivement érité une entreprise mais
qui a tellement développé qu'on peut
dire qu'il l'a pas que créé euh parce
queelle n'a rien à voir c'est qu'il
qu'il a hérité je crois que de mémoire
devait faire 70 millions d'euros il a
passé à 200 280 enfin il il a explosé C
entreprise en terme de développement
donc il a il a été un créateur d'emploi
il était un créateur de richesse et
c'est de terrain donc effectivement euh
durcir c'est pas durcir le le mot était
peut-être pas choisi ou approprié c'est
c'est Pierre Gata c'est l'homme d'un
combat pour l'entreprise d'un combat
pour l'emploi et et je suis très
solidaire avec lui de ce côté-là euh
parce que quand les entreprises vont
bien et d'ailleurs il l'a prouvé dans
son parcours quandreise se développe
qu'elle se crée elle crée de l'emploi
elle crée de la richesse et c'est bien
pour tout le monde h Laurence Pariso qui
lui a qui qui lui a précédé n'a pas pu
faire un troisème mandat c'était dans
les statuts même si elle l'aurait plutôt
plutôt souhaité et elle s'intéressait à
des sujets sociétaux véritablement c'est
ça qui a tranché aussi avec le style
pierre gataz vous préférez lequel des
deux à choisir je pense qu'ils sont
indissociables il y a pas de choix à
faire euh il faut affirmer les valeurs
pour moi ce qui apporte c'est c'est
justement que les réconcilier il faut
réconcilier les salariés et l'entreprise
les Français et l'entreprise
l'entreprise c'est la vie l'entreprise
c'est la vie c'est vrai que c'est le
moteur c'est que c'est un moteur qui
permet de de développer de créer il n'y
a pas de richesse sans
entreprise donc il y a pas à choisir
entre le sociétal ou l'économie c'est un
c'est un mix il faut allier les deux une
ce qui se développe elle va bien avec
ces deux ces deux
on va mettre fin à cette première
séquence d'émission je vous propose
néanmoins d'écouter un micro trottoir
nous sommes allés demander un petit peu
au cquantinois aux ivblinois selon eux à
quoi servait le MDEF et puis bien sûr
vous pourrez leur répondre réagir après
selon vous est-ce que c'est utile un
syndicat pour les patrons bah je suppose
puisque les un syndicat pour les
ouvriers pourquoi pas un syndicat pour
les patrons est-ce que c'est utile de
défendre les
patrons bah oui malgré tout tout le
monde a besoin de se défendre bon pas
grandchose en fait hein pourquoi
justement ça ser pas grand chose Mo je
sais pas à part nous enfoncer à part
d'être des pions je vois pas ce qu'on
est pour eux il y a bien des syndicats
au niveau des ouvriers il faut bien
qu'au niveau du patronat il y ait des
organismes pour centraliser différentes
actions ça nous ça sert à nous embêter
je pense que les les gens qui qui
travaillent doivent se poser beaucoup de
questions et le poids qu'il a
vis-à-vis du du gouvernement actuel non
justement le medf c'est quoi ça c'est un
organisme de lobby c'est fait pour
embêter les salariés ce qu'on a entendu
dans le micro trottoir alors ça c'est
amusant mais non mais c'est amusant et
c'est très routatif de de d'état de
pensée aujourd'hui on enevient au
cliché pour moi il y a pas opposé patron
et salarié opposer entreprise et salarié
c'est un nonsens on va s'intéresser à
présent à vous à votre parcours et aussi
l'autre l'autre aspect puisque vous êtes
aussi chef d'entreprise ça on va venir
au cours de la seconde partie de de ce
café politique je vous laisse passer en
salle à présent
[Musique]
allez-y invité de ce café politique
Bertrand decé le président du MDEF des
ivelines on a parlé tout à l'heure de
votre organisation mais finalement on a
assez peu parlé de vous vous devenez
président du du MF des ivelines en 2011
novembre 2011 qu'est-ce qui vous a
poussé à ce moment-là à prendre la tête
de l'organisation dans le
département chemin si vous voulez j'ai
j'ai créé une entreprise euh j'ai d cré
ma première entreprise en
et avec tous les affres de la
création sa quand on conise on est comme
messiveuse tout vous tombe dessus on
découvre on fait et puis puis les choses
heureusement ça s'agisse
et et après il y a un besoin de un
besoin d'engagement parce que quand on
quand on a réussi il y a deux solutions
où on profite et et et on s'abstrait du
monde où on se dit tiens je peux agir et
j'avais un besoin d'agir je voulais pas
le faire en politique j'ai choisi le
mond de patronal vous aviez déjà eu un
engagement plus jeune que ce soit en
politique ou dans le monde syndical
aussi aucun aucun
aucun c'est c'est c'est une vision des
choses je pensais que j'ai passé pas de
ma vie à apprendre comme tout le
monde j'ai une vie de salari ù j'ai
travaillé j'ai une vie d'entrepreneur et
et aujourd'hui je suis en phase j'ai 57
ans je suis en phase d'ailleursis de
transmettre mon entreprise et et je dis
que le temps libre que que j'ai pu
libérer et bien je le
donne un combat qui me paraît légitime
vous êtes directeur d'un supermarché on
va pas citer la marque vous avez une
soixantaine de salariés c'est à Fontenel
fleur un petit peu moins maintenant cque
mon un peu les chiffres est-ce que
est-ce que justement cet aspect là vous
sert dans votre travail ce travail
pardon vous sert dans votre aspect
d'engagement syndical ah complètement
mais tout à fait moi je pense qu'on ne
peut pas être un bon président de MDF si
on n'est pas soiême chez l'entreprise et
je dirais même que le fait d'avoir vécu
la création la maturité et la
transmission font que j'ai vécu toutes
les phases de l'entreprise le fait
d'avoir été salarié aussi savez moi
c'est ce que je disais je m'exprimais
avec un leader CGT l'autre jour
sa li j'ai été licencié j'ai été au Pr
en tant que salarié je pense que tout
mon parcours et toute mon expérience me
sert mais j'ai été employeur j'ai eu des
employés que j'ai licencié j'ai vécu
tout les affres de C donc savez c'est la
vie c'est la vie et je pense que il faut
avoir vécu et et je dirais que c'est
peut-être je rebondis sur ce que vous
dites peut-être reproche que je
fais à certains de
leçon c'est eux n'ont jamais créé de
richesse jamais créé d'emploi euh jamais
vécu ces choses-là moi je les ai V o les
donneurs de leçon alors je veux pas me
faire desnemis donc on va vous les
trouverez vousmême un peu partout so
alors voilà quelle que soit la formation
si vous voulez je pense que si on avait
plus d'hommes et de femmes euh qui qui
prennent les manettes du pouvoir en
ayant vécu réellement ce que vit le
peuple franç
on aurait peut-être des directions plus
intéressantes le peuple en tout cas une
partie était dans la rue aujourd'hui 9
mars date d'enregistrement de cette
émission il y avait cette mobilisation
manifestation la première contre cette
loi travail qui sera étudiée à partir du
24 mars sauf si elle est à nouveau
reporter et que le gouvernement recule
un petit peu salariés des étudiants qui
sont dans la rue comment vous l'avez
vécu cette journée lorsque vous voyez
des salariés des étudiants dans la rue
quand vous voyez des banderoll
d'ailleurs comme on a pu le voir contre
le MDEF im G immense gâie parce que si
cette loi visiblement ne satisfait pas
la rue mais n satisfit pas non plus
c'est pas notre loi tout n'est pas
bien nous pensons globalement on
apprécie plutôt cette réforme attendez
je vais mesurer ce que je veux dire
c'est une bonne direction ça va dans le
bon sens et et et les choses névueront
pas en un coup de baguette magique donc
c'est bien et aujourd'hui cette loi est
totalement incomprise incomprise euh et
et et alors bon j'ai un autre sujet
d'étonnement qui sont les étudiants h et
les lycéens en ce qui me concerne je
pense c'est assez alerte sur les choses
économiques et politique bien documenté
j'ai pris le temps et il m'a fallu un
peu de temps pour bien regarder les
mesures et surtout surtout vraiment
comment je pouvais transposer ces
mesures h enant
d'entreprise est-ce que chez vous ça moi
je suis étonné qu'un gamin de 16 ans ou
17 ans puisse me
dire très rapidement qu'il est contre
par ce qu' les inquiète c'est la
précarisation de se dire on va arriver
sur le marché du travail on sera V la
vraie
précarisation c'est le chômage l'emploi
c'est pas précaire quand on ça dépend
des conditions d'emploi est-ce que on
est employé est-ce qu'on a une garantie
de cet emploi là est-ce que du jour au
lendemain on peut se retrouver à la rue
quel sera notre salaire aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui euh il y a pour moi deux
aspects on est au boulot ou au chômage
donc là la précarité c'est le chômage
donc vraiment le le point numéro 1 c'est
créer de l'emploi et recruter que les
gens aient un emploi après aujourd'hui
je pense que les les le monde a changé
l'entreprise a changé les entreprises
ont besoin d'agilité elles ont besoin de
de de visibilité de sécurité et et les
entreprises on ne sont pas ne vivent pas
comme unu tranquille une emprise qui
produit
une entreprise qui saisonnière qui va
avir des variations une entreprise qui
va avoir des des des des des des pics de
production elle va devoir adapter sa
masse salariale et on peut trouver des
équilibres l'idée c'est la recherche
d'équilibre quand on on nous dit on
pourra tiens avec 4 mois de de de de
baisse de d'activité pourouvoir Ener moi
je dis 4 mois est-ce que c'est la bonne
notion 4 mois peut-être 6 discutons h
disc sur sur sur
l'intérêt c'est que l'entreprise
prospère et continue pour qu'elle
puissent embaucher des nouveaux salariés
et réduire le
chômage après s'il faut à une entreprise
qui qui a qui paye trop de charge
sociale qui paye trop de frais sociaux
qui paye trop de charges elle meurt au
bout moment elle dépose le bilan mais un
salarié qui même pour la survie de son
entreprise doit voir baisser son salaire
on va aussi se retrouver face à certain
pas question de baisser le salaire là de
manière
provisoire
il pas question dans cette loi il n'est
jamais question de baisser le salaire on
ne baisse pas le salaire on adapte les
temps de travail sur des temps on peut à
des moments qu'est-ce qu'il faut à un
moment imaginez une entreprise tiens qui
qui vivent une grave crise pour une
raison
X s'il faut à un moment donné licencier
20 % de l'entreprise en chômage
économique pour passer la vague c'est
préserver les 80 autes% et quand elle a
passé la vague elle récupère les vins et
elle rebarre c'est c'est une chose
vivante l'entreprise c'est pas c'est pas
un monde immuable on passe pas à 20 à 30
vous savez un truc en plus pour moi il y
a pas de débat je vous parler en
entrepreneur pour moi il y a pas de
débat un entrepreneur il n qu'une envie
mais qu'une envie c'est faire prospérer
son entreprise c'est la développer et
s'il la développe ben il crée des
richesses il crée de l'emploi mais je
connais pas un entrepreneur dig de ce
nom qui dis écoutez moi j'ai envie de
licencier j'ai envie de baisser mon
chiffre d'affaires j'ai envie que mon
entreprise devienne moribonde il y en a
pas un qui va vous
dire mais les mesures qui sont dans
cette dans cette réforme en tout cas
telle qu'elle sera sans doute présenté
le 24 mars vous vous seriez élu vous la
voteriez par
exemple et ensuite vous l'appliqueriez
avec joie dans votre entreprise attendez
on va prendre des mesures des mesures
simples euh le
plafonnement un petit prudom mal qui
serait limité à qui ne dépasserait pas
15 mois de salaire 15 mois salaire c'est
quand Mme 15 mois de salaire quand même
pour un salarié qui est là depuis 20 25
ans dans une entreprise quel intérêt le
l'idée c'est pas de travailler sur le
nombre de mois d'indemnité c'est de
faire en sorte que ce salarier retrouve
très vite du boulot très vite du boulot
qui ait du plein emploi qui a du
recrutement qui a besoin de lui l'idée
c'est sa formation l'idée c'est
travailler qualifications et que cette
salarié qui a été licencié qui a toucher
15 mois de salaire puisse retrouver un
emploi dans les 3 mois ou les 4 mois
c'est ça l'idée de travail c'est là
qu'il faut travailler c'est pas c'est
pas sur lui donner 20 mois ou 30 mois
parce que toute façon ça c'est pas une
mesure péren c'est ça la vraie précarité
elle est là elle est là alors faut-il
l'imposer cette loi cette loi réforme du
travail peut-être par l'article 493
pourquoi pas en tout cas nous avons
poser la question je vous laisse
répondre enite bah s'il est convaincu
que c'est la bonne chose il devra le
faire c'est nous qui vivons aussi dans
ce pays quoi donc que si on éécoute pas
son peuple on peut pas avancer tous
ensemble non nul n'a besoin d'imposer
quel quoi que ce soit pour
le n'importe quelle loi si on retire
totalement la loi c'est un peu absurde
aussi il faut négocier pe retour aux
négociations c'est la bon imposé non
c'est pas la bonne solution de toute
façon il on ils sont déjà en train de
faire machine àrière de toute manière
bah normalement le gouvernement est le
représentant du du peuple donc
normalement il devrait écouter le peuple
on a voté pour avoir des représentants
qui fait le boulot donc on va pas faire
le boulot à leur place voilà donc c'est
au gouvernement et aux députés euh de
faire leur job donc d'assumer leur
projet exactement on les a élus pour ça
il faut l'imposer alors votre réponse je
pense que la dernière la dernière dame à
à à ça c'est une fonction de la
démocratie pour moi a parfaitement
raison nous sommes en
démocratie nous
élisons des des hommes et des femmes h
pour nous représenter et et et donc
si nous avons donné mandat et élu ces
hommes pour la durée de leur mandat nous
devons leur faire confiance mais ça
c'est une fonction démocratique pour moi
si l'élu doit être tributaire de la rue
au quotidien je pense qu'on avancera
jamais sauf lorsque parce que c'est le
cas aujourd'hui dans la rue on manifeste
parce qu'on dit que le gouvernement a
trahi par rapport aux propositions qui
av été fait sur un programme que cette
loi si vous voulez la façon a manqué de
pédagogie on aurait dû expliquer
davantage aur dû proposer
discuter si vous voulez s' un reproche
que je ferai au ministre c'est c'est
surtout sur la forme pas sur le fond ça
se fait aussi un peu dans la
précipitation il reste un peu à peine
plus d'un an avant les
prochaines maintenant sur la forme je je
pense qu'il aurait fallu expliquer
davantage et et encore une fois si vous
voulez le MF c'est pas la loi du BDF
c'est pas ce que nous voulons il y a
plein de choses qu'on a critiqué dans
cette loi nous nous disons
simplement ça va dans le bon sens à
partir du moment où nous pourrons dans
les choses que nous avons c'est en plus
cette possibilité de référendum
peut-être intéressante euh vous savez je
vous le disais en début d'entretien euh
la France est un est un pays de PME euh
un chef d'entreprise bah moi tout
simplement mais mais mais et tous mes
camarades et encore moi j'ai une très
grosse entreprise si vous prenez leur
min C h euh 96 ou 94 je crois pour des
entreprises ont moins de 10 salariés en
France je crois que à peu près ça donc
avec 40 Etel salariés je suis dans les
dans les 6 % plus grosses
entreprises et pourtant je connais tous
mes salariés par leur prénom et par leur
nom je leur dis bonjour individuellement
tous les jours j'ai àire des êtres
humains et et et et chez nous pourquoi
il y a très peu de représent syndical
c'est que le dialogue social il est
quotidien et il y a pas d'adversaire
c'est pas un patron si vous voulez si je
devais je rentre pas dans mon entreprise
encadré de vigile avec des des CRS je
vois des hommes tous les et des femmes
tous les matins qui me sourient et quand
ils ont un problème ils m'en parlent et
on en discute mais ça c'est la réalité
des entreprises alors il n'y a peut-être
ça se passe pas toujours bien oui parce
que là vous dépignez un climat idéal
dans une situation idéal c'est pas
toujours le cas j'ai un peu peur faut
aussi encadrer quelquefis les des qu'
qu'on ait tendance à à mettre en avant
si vous voulez tout ce qui va mal euh et
ce qui va bien vous savez tiens regardez
j'ai une anecdote à vous citer quand
j'ai créé mon entreprise en 2005 enfin
celle-là celle que j'ai que que je
dirige actuellement
euh nous étions euh dans mon enseigne
qu'on citera pas euh nous avons créé
collectivement au même
moment 200 ou 220 emplois h HM et à la
même époque Moulinex en Normandie
licencié 210 personnes on a parlé ça a
fait la une des journaux télévisés de
TF1 anenne 2 machin les deux sont même
pas détruits mais construit on a jamais
parlé toujours des trains qui arriv en
retardar à exactement mais oui mais
pourtant il y a plus de train qui
arrivent à l'heure que de trains qui
arrivent en retard c'est à 36 ans que
vous êtes devenu patron euh tout à fait
36 ans gérant donc de d'un hypermarché
qui va plutôt mal à ce moment super
super super vous don donz des grands
trucs dans j'avais pas un sou j'ai
racheté une boîte
totalement je l'ai acheté un franc je
l'ai acheté un franc alors vous imaginez
quand on achète un franc une entreprise
c'est qu'elle va très très très mal
alors qu'est-ce qui explique là ce
parcours et cette décision d'acheter
cette entreprise de vous lancer de vous
dire Mo je serai patron même si j'achète
une entreprise qui va mal et que ça me
coûte un franc si vous voulez d'abord
alors d'abord j'avais pas le choix
j'avais pas le choix parce que j'avais
pas
d'argent donc je voulais entreprendre et
et il y a il y a un petit côté fou dans
l'entreprise il y a un petit côté un
petit côté Christophe Colom je vais
découvrir l'Amérique alors que tout le
monde P qu'on va tomber au fond quoi il
y en a un qui dit bah non je vais
trouver la route des Indes et non tu vas
tomber il y a des monstres tu vas te
planter au bout donc tout le monde lu va
se planter vous étiez convaincu que vous
allez redess j'ai cru en moi voilà
c'était c'est je c'est le côté
Christophe colon quoi on dit je suis sûr
que là-bas je ça était aussi facile que
ça durissime durissime si vouz j'étais
salarié en plus j'étais j'étais des
cadres supérieurs deun jolie total
j'étais directeur des ventes de la
filiale
Spontex euh donc j'avais tous les
avantages de ma fonction me retrouver au
four au moulin c'est que d'abord le
sacrifice ces weekends comme tous
salariés ben j'avais mes weekends mais
cette semaine de Cong j'ai payé tout ça
et du jour au lendemain ben
j'ai vacances h4our sur 7 C H24 7/ 7
mais aventure passionnante aventure
passionnante et et quand je jette un
regard maintenant sur cette période je
me dis merci j'étais sportif costaud
j'avais la force physique parce que
c'est ce qui m' de tenir quand on est
des banquiers qui vous sautent dessus
qui qui vous suppriment vos lignes de
crédit des fournisseurs qui vous qui qui
des tout tout allait dans le mauvais
sens et et et c'est un vrai combat mais
c'est passionnant mais c'est passionnant
et et et et j'ai tout appris dans ce
combat d'ailleurs ça vous a servi donc
ensuite pour prendre de responsabilité
un peu plus au MF par exemple quand vous
disiez tout à l'heure j'étais salarié
moi avant j'aiétaé licencié aussi je
sais ce que c'est ça ça me sert quand je
discute avec
syicatz et quand je discute parce que le
MDEF est le seul mouvement qui fait tout
le spectre l'entreprise nous on a des
TPE des PME et on a le C40 donc on a
tout le spectre et quand entrepreneur
qui dit tu sais Bertrand la création
c'est dur je sais j'ai fait ça je suis
passé par là quand je discute avec un
type qui a 6 se salariés mais j'ai connu
cette période j'ai connu la période où
les banquier me disait non
systématiquement où on m'a appelit on
m'a appelit presque trois fois par jour
pour me dire combien est-ce que j'avais
sur le compte parce que parce que le
compte était en rouge j'ai connu cette
période et aujourd'hui ça va mieux bah
aujourd'hui ça va beaucoup mieux parce
que cette affaire là ensuite vous l'avez
revendu et alors je l'ai je l'ai je l'ai
remonté revendu et et d'ailleurs tiens
encore anecdote c'est c'est là où le
virus est un virus mon fils qui m'a
rejoint aujourd'hui mais était encore
jeune à l'époque il me dit mais papa
pourquoi est-ce que tu ne ne profites
pas de l'argent que tu as gagné pour
t'acheter bon une belle maison un B truc
et puis reprends un métier que tu sais
faire dis non non je préférais avoir une
baraque de frit et être seul être mon
maître mais ça c'est c'est une vocation
c'est votre prochain projet projet je
dire il est plutôt maintenant je vais
vous dire vous savez je pense qu'il faut
pas'rocher au pouvoir j'ai fait en sorte
j'ai fait voter des statutes dans monlè
territorial sur quel on ne peut pas
seterelà de de mandats donc je vais
peut-être prolonger d'un mandat on sera
mon deuxème ce sera terminé et je pense
Clement il faut céder la place aux
autres je transfis mon entreprise à mon
fils et après vous ferez de la politique
après non je pense que j'ai j'ai deux
petitte fill j'espère avoir d'autres
petits enfants et je pense à chacun je
fait plaisir et je pense que vers 67 ans
c'est l'âge à peu près à laquelle je
compte
m'arrêter je m'occuperai de ma famille
et j'espère être un grand père heureux
j'ai une dernière vidéo à vous vous
faire regarder écouter est-ce que vous
connaissez Frédéric Fromet qui
intervient sur France Inter chaque jour
à 17h voilà il a une petite vidéo en ce
moment j'ai tout plein d'amis au
m ma religion c'est le
BF pour faire du pogon je vendrai père
et mère le laisser aller du pauvre
m'exaspère j'ai tout plein d'amis au
MF ma religion c'est le
BF mon dieu c'est le patron qui vire qui
dégraisse et qui impunément se tire avec
la caiss ça vous fait sourire ouais ça
me fait rire oui ça vous fait rire on
revient à ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure
sur cette image un petit peu cliché clé
c'est mais c'est drôle non mais c'est
drôle mais ça reste drôle c'est pour moi
c'est drôle oui c'est drôle c'est j'ai
plein d'amis au MDE ma religion c'est le
BF c'est une caricature c'estd que le
type qui casse avec la caisse je fais
des poillons mais mais mais mais ça
fonctionne pas ça ne fonctionne
pas des mecs qu'est-ce que mais attendez
un type qui crée sa boîte il se tire
avec la caiss qu'est-ce qu'il fait après
il fait quoi après comment on fait pour
m'exque comment on fait pour avec la CAE
et je peux vous assurer sincèrement que
c'est pas ce qui me guide c'est surtout
pas le profil c'est pas le profil pas le
BF pour revenir à cette chans c'est pas
le
bfci d'avoir participé à ce café
politique merci
deavirité
[Musique]